non mais sérieux à passer au tableau
passion le tableau
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
domicile mokhtar est actuellement chez
un de nos chroniqueurs on a réussi à se
procurer les clés de l'un d'entre vous
et mokhtar s'est introduit chez lui
mokhtar est ce que vous pouvez montrer
un premier objet pour voir si la
personne comprend que c'est chez lui
tout de suite ou pas ce que vous avez un
premier objet allez-y mokhtar mokhtar
est ce que vous avez un truc
ah ouais est ce que quelqu'un
reconnaisse à comment quelqu'un
reconnaît ça c'est pas chez vous déjà
christophe carrière a lâché lime mais
comment tu veux qu'on reconnaît
s'annonce comme ça c'est quelqu'un qui
cuisinent par koné pa sak as roma 2e
objet mokhtar chez moi rocca serra
deuxième objet c'est quoi ça un
parapluie et papa tient pas depuis rouge
c'est pas chez moi s'est passé vous j'ai
pas chez vous non qu'ils commencent à se
dire que c'est chez lui un vieux doute
jean michel gentil sec
vous avez parapluies rouges y a pas plus
de golf où je tirais vous n'avez pas
motard est ce qu'on peut aller voir chez
pas placer vous devant la télé par
exemple passé vous devant la télé placez
vous devant la télé
c'est là qu'ils à ce chien qui associa
et oui c'est chez jean michel 2
j'ambitionne heures
ou pas
et en direct que c'est jean-michel vert
alors le jeu est très simple
jean michel vous avez une relation très
particulière avec thierry mots j'ai
compris que son chien généraux
vous avez une relation très particulière
je vais donc posé des questions à
thierry moreau et à chaque fois
si thierry moreau aurait tombale mokhtar
fera ce qu'il a à faire
marie s'échauffent j'étais eux je suis
pas dans la même voiture mais pas encore
ceux de mes beaux ou tard mokhtar
calmez-vous ces bons reconnaît reculer
vous tous soir la télé c'est bon c'est
bon
s'ils ont une question pour thierry
moreau oh la vache chéri moreau voici la
première question qu'on va vous poser
mon chien oui ou de quelle couleur
de quelle couleur est la nouvelle
voiture de jean michel mer noire c'est
une bonne réponse elle est bien noir la
veille
[Applaudissements]
attention hein la question est facile
thierry moreau comment s'appelle le
modèle de cette table d'un proposition
view star ou grichka furst à mokhtar
mokhtar poser c'est si oui c'est poser
c'est si c'est le droit de réponse à sa
paire bien bien ses actions
voici voici la question mokhtar
mettez-vous devant le placard mettez
vous debout le placard mokhtar parce que
je posais une nouvelle question à
thierry moreau allez-vous mettre devant
le placard mokhtar attention thierry
moreau combien de caleçons possède jean
michel maire combien de caleçons poser
raid
jean michel mr 0 skipper pas de dessous
motard est ce qu'on peut vérifier mon
père de caleçons possède jean michel mr
mokhtar mokhtar ombre et le placard
allez-y allez-y voilà voilà les kabyles
en d'année calcio ah oui elle a déjà
donné à beaucoup d'égards
mokhtar tard bahia n'a pu hélas plus et
la passion et elle a beaucoup
mokhtar mettez pas votre malade horn
dans la trappe et les maladies
voilà ses bras les gibbons allégis
mokhtar relever tous les cats ont
regardé ce qui à les y aller l'imoca
chiens attaquent edgar à aller à ces
mots rares la deux
oui allez vite vous allez vite potard
attention
oui
[Applaudissements]
et ça n'est pas un truc à je n'allais
pas d'un truc à ce motard tourner dans
le salon mokhtar combats y at il deux
queues de cerises un an sur cette oeuvre
après ce sommet at-il de queues de
cerises sur cette oeuvre ben là c'est
bon allez alesi ornements plus le
tableau on ne montre plus le tableau
s'il vous plaît mais la regardant c'est
dans ce but il y en a 15 case mokhtar à
l'egypte en fait un petit peu la
peinture chez jean-michel reprennent
après la pâture motards n'ont jamais
charia pas sur le tableau pas sur le
tableau
mais pas sur le tableau
non
jamais dit fassions les tableaux les
motards savoir c'est moi c'est mon choix
c'est beau c'est bon c'est leur retard
motta c'est bon c'est bon
mokhtar on va retourner dans la chambre
noire balance et moi ce alors balancé
mois sa part la snet alesi motards
ça va ça va a été passé passé devraient
amender ou 20 motards n'ont jamais vos
cartes et souvent ils font l'objet
je suis sage ceci rend malade maloka je
crois que sa maladie il fait tout ce
qu'on lui nicolas saada me
il se doit
[Applaudissements]
mostar moka je crois qu'on a on a on a
tapé à la porte
autant je crois qu'on a ce les motards
on tape à la porte
ouais bah tu vas nous le dira
[Applaudissements]
non
et
latrobe faisant leur
bon allez suivre
michèle janisset avant longtemps